Hochbetrieb in der Münchner Notaufnahme
neun Behandlungsräume und der
Akutbereich sind voll die Patienten
stapeln sich auf den Fluren für Florian
Lemming und sein Team kaum zu schaffen
jeder Tag hier ist ohne Pause die
psychische Belastung ist extrem hoch und
die Krankmeldungen nehmen zu weil wir
auch eine Umgebung haben die krank macht
muss man sagen permanenter Stress
permanente Unzufriedenheit es sei der
ganz normale Wahnsinn so gehe es schon
seit Wochen so Oberärztin roßbach-weg
der Grund von 16 Notaufnahmen in München
haben sich 13 von der Notrufleitstelle
abgemeldet sprich sie sind im Augenblick
überlastet haben zu viele Patienten
und können die eben nicht zeitgerecht
versorgen die Folge die Patienten werden
von den Rettungsdiensten hier
eingeliefert dabei ist es jetzt schon
eng hier sind mehr als alle Plätze
belegt durch den Personalmangel in der
Pflege sind wir schon lange mit halber
Besetzung zu viele Patienten zu wenig
Personalausfälle auch durch Corona das
bedeutet mehr Arbeit auf weniger
Schultern Schicht für Schicht ohne Pause
ein 96-jähriger Mensch ist vom
Rettungsdienst eingeliefert worden
Pflegekraft leer versucht dem älteren
Herrn die Angst zu nehmen seit kurzem
arbeitet die 20-Jährige hier eigentlich
ihr Traumjob doch man kommt jeden Tag
mit einem schlechten Bauchgefühl schon
in die Arbeit wenn man weiß man kann die
Patienten nicht so versorgen wie man sie
eigentlich versorgen möchte wir hatten
hier schon so oft die Situation wo ich
hier da stand einfach geweint habe weil
ich nicht mehr wusste wie ich das machen
sollte wie lange Lea das noch aushält
sie weiß es nicht einige haben das Team
mittlerweile verlassen
verlassen fühlt sich auch Christoph
Meisel seit über vier Stunden liegt der
hier mit verdrehten Knie und fühlt sich
halt hier verloren also ich kann nicht
laufen aber trotzdem kommt keiner der
hilft und ist halt die Nummer und und
liegt hier rum und die Leute gehen hier
vorbei als wäre mir
hat starke Schmerzen Verdacht auf eine
gerissene Sehne über vier Stunden
warten sie
und hat jemand schon nach ihm geguckt
nee trotz Nierensteinen und langem
Warten zeigt Stefan Bagger Verständnis
für die Situation ich bin ein bisschen
erschrocken gewesen weil man hört
natürlich immer da ist wenig Personal
viel los man hat dann selber betroffen
ist dann ist es mal was anderes dann
dann kriegt man das einfach mal so mit
wie so wirklich ist ein ständiges Ringen
für alle hier Stationsleiter Florian
liebt seinen Beruf doch bei allem
Engagement fühlt er sich über dem Limit
diese Flut von Patienten in Kombination
mit einem starken Personalmangel
sorgt dafür dass das Leute hier nach
Hause gehen und immer das Gefühl haben
sie haben nicht richtig versorgt und
Menschen nicht so helfen können wie sie
es wollen schnell und effektiv seit
sechs Stunden wartet Hermann Westermeier
nach einer OP bekam der 82-Jährige zu
Hause Herzprobleme
muss heute noch stationär abgedruckt
werden doch das kann dauern denn auch
auf normalen Stationen sind Betten
Mangelware das führt dazu dass die
Patienten die hierher kommen und die
stationär aufgenommen werden müssen dass
wir kein Bett für sie haben und die
Patienten entsprechend in der
Notaufnahme Liegen statt 900 sind in der
Klinik derzeit nur knapp 600 Betten
verfügbar die Folge Stau auf der
Notaufnahme
die Situation im Münchner Notfallzentrum
kein Einzelfall laut einer bundesweiten
Umfrage leiden 98% von 360 Notaufnahmen
und der Personalmangel 86% melden sich
immer wieder von den Rettungsleitstellen
ab weil sie voll sind
die Überbelastung der Notaufnahmen ist
ich in ganz Deutschland sehr ausgeprägt
aber wir versuchen alles die
Patientensicherheit aufrecht zu erhalten
aber natürlich in Phasen mit hohem
Stress kann es auch mal passieren dass
die Patientensicherheit dann gefährdet
ist heißt
das Diagnosen
übersehen werden heißt das
möglicherweise auch Behandlung verzögert
werden der Stress in den Kliniken setzt
sich bei den Rettungsdiensten fort sind
die Notaufnahmen dicht ist es Ihr
Problem die schwerkranken unterzubringen
denn im Gegensatz zu den Kliniken können
sie sich nicht abmelden wir sind einfach
ein schwaches Bindeglied dazwischen was
alles ausbaden muss das ist eine
Krankenhaus hat sich abgemeldet und so
langsam sind alle vom Netz gegangen und
wird zum Transportzeiten von einer
Stunde nichts Unnormales und wir kriegen
die Patienten ins Auto wir kriegen sie
denn aber nicht mehr im Krankenhaus los
Ortswechsel Hochbetrieb in der
romed-klinik in Rosenheim im Minutentakt
kommen die Rettungswagen zur Notaufnahme
mit Fahrzeiten über einer Stunde aus 50
km Entfernung dennoch geht hier was aber
immer natürlich unter der Vorgabe dass
der lebensbedrohliche Lebens erkrankte
Patienten natürlich den Vorrang hat
über 100 Notfallpatienten werden hier
pro Tag behandelt im Jahr rund 40.000
die rohmetklinik ist weit und breit der
einzige notfallversorger im südlichen
Oberbayern das heißt jeder stationär
behandlungsbedürftige Notfall kommt zu
uns und darauf verlassen sich die
Menschen Tag und Nacht und wenn Romed
nicht liefern kann dann gibt es keine
Alternative abmelden praktisch nicht
möglich denn der nächste Versorger ist
weit weg mittendrin Doris Feiler sie
organisiert das ganze was sie alle in
der ohnehin angespannten Situation nervt
bringt sie auf den Punkt dass wir ganz
viele Patienten haben die nicht
unbedingt zu uns kommen müssen
vielleicht auch mal beim
Bereitschaftsarzt oder beim Hausarzt
ganz gut aufgehoben werden
die nehmen uns die Ressourcen die nehmen
uns die Plätze weg die nehmen uns die
Zeit weg Zeit die an anderer Stelle
dringend benötigt wird auch mal zum
Innehalten ein Patient ist gestorben
trotz großem ein konnten sie ihn nicht
retten wir haben den Patienten eine
Katze aufgestellt in seinem Zimmer das
ist für mich persönlich ganz ganz
wichtig und wenn es bloß zehn Minuten
sind aber ich brauche dann schon auch
die Zeiten so ein bisschen Abschied zu
nehmen und den Fall abzuschließen die
53-Jährige habe schon mal daran gedacht
aufzuhören doch wenn alle dies täten wer
macht es dann zurück in die Münchner
Notaufnahme eine junge Frau wurde nach
einem schweren Unfall eingeliefert das
Team kümmert sich um sie andere
Notfallpatienten müssen jetzt warten
doch nicht alle haben Geduld und die
stressen das Team zusätzlich
Patienten die sich dann super laut
beschweren dass sie hier nicht sofort
behandelt werden und null Verständnis
für diese Situation haben um die
Dringlichkeit festzustellen wird bereits
bei der Aufnahme der Zustand des
Notfallpatienten gecheckt
wer muss in die Notaufnahme und wer
nicht sind die Hausarztpraxen
geschlossen und die Erkrankung nicht
lebensbedrohlich hilft der ärztliche
Bereitschaftsdienst unter der
bundesweiten Telefonnummer
116117 akute Bauch- oder Rückenschmerzen
etwa aber auch Hals oder Ohrenschmerzen
und fiebrige Erkältungen werden hier
behandelt die Notaufnahme im Krankenhaus
ist für lebensbedrohliche Fälle gedacht
etwa bei plötzlich auftretenden sehr
starken Beschwerden bei Unfällen bei
Schlaganfällen oder Herzinfarkten auch
Komplikationen in der Schwangerschaft
Vergiftungen und Suizidversuche gehören
hierher
trotz aller Bemühungen gelingt es nicht
immer Menschen leben zu retten
Pflegekraft Sandra bleibt obwohl ihr
Dienstzeit Stunden zu Ende ist
für die Kollegin heißt es dass die jetzt
den Sterbeprozess eines Patienten
begleitet um das noch halbwegs würdig zu
gestalten
bleibt diese Kollegin jetzt freiwillig
länger auf unbestimmte Zeiten die
nächste Hiobsbotschaft eine
Mitarbeiterin hat sich krank gemeldet
fällt dem Spätdienst aus das bedeutet
noch mehr Arbeit auf wenigen Schultern
nicht mitziehen ist keine Option es geht
immer um Menschen um Patienten oder
Hilfe suchende Menschen und da aus
dieser Sache kommt man nicht raus also
da kann man dann nicht sagen so jetzt
ist aber Schluss und ich gehe nach Hause
doch ständig am Limit ist auch keine
Option der Notruf aus der Notaufnahme er
sollte endlich gehört werden